die überreste einer gigantischen anlage
in den bergen die enormen kräften
standhalten sollte was ist das und warum
ist es explodiert
eine geisterstadt verlassen und dem
verfall preisgegeben
wie ein riese der in die knie gezwungen
wurde sofort
seltsame militärische hafenanlagen die
von geheimnissen eines unterwasser-
kriegs zeugen
plötzlich 200 meter entfernt
was ist das und
ein massiver betonbau auf dem platten
land
man wäre sicher überrascht plötzlich auf
diese anlage mitten im nirgendwo zu
stoßen
sie zählten einmal zu den
fortschrittlichsten bauwerken ihrer zeit
mit das modernste was ingenieurs und
baukunst zu bieten hatten dann wurden
diese anlagen aufgegeben manche sind
heute lebensgefährlich verseucht aber
wer hat sie erschaffen und wie und warum
wurden sie wieder aufgegeben
[Musik]
in italien hoch in den zentralalpen
steht ein riesiger betonbau
eindrucksvoll wie eine kathedrale
[Musik]
jeder gut 40 meter aus dem tal emporragt
wird er fast wie von einer anderen welt
wie eine festung aus der herr der ringe
dieser verwitterte grauer beton hoch in
den bergen
[Musik]
so eine anlage in der überwältigenden
natur mit den bergen und dem see und
dann kommt man auf die andere seite und
denkt was ist denn hier passiert
wäre der bau intakt würde er sich von
einer seite des tals zur anderen
erstrecken
aber mittendrin ist eine große lücke
vor jahrzehnten wurde das mittelstück
aus dieser riesigen mauer herausgerissen
waren es bomben war es ein erdbeben
es muss ein katastrophales ereignis
gewesen sein
wie konnte etwas augenscheinlich so
stabiles derart spektakulär
zusammenbrechen
was geschah also und werfen neue
erkenntnisse vielleicht ein anderes
licht auf den einsturz
die geschichte führt uns zurück in die
jahre vor dem ersten weltkrieg italien
ist darum bemüht zu europas
industriellen großmächten aufzuschließen
[Applaus]
der fortschritt hält vor allem im norden
des landes ein zug während der süden
wirtschaftlich stagniert in der folge
ziehen viele menschen in die großen
städte wie turin oder mailand die schon
bald über bevölkert sind
und das obwohl zwischen 1900 und dem
beginn des ersten weltkriegs rund drei
millionen italiener vorrangig aus dem
süden in der hoffnung auf ein besseres
leben in die usa auswandern
um genug strom für die neuen fabriken
produzieren zu können investieren
derweil wohlhabende geschäftsleute in
wasserkraftwerke in den alpen
das sind die überreste eines solchen
projekts der rhino talsperre
sie wurde in schwierigen zeiten erbaut
als anarchisten fabriken besetzen und
vereinzelt sogar bomben zünden
[Musik]
in norditalien herrschten enorme
politische unruhen
es gab die kapitalisten und gleichzeitig
eine starke kommunistische bewegung die
sich das alles ganz anders vorstellte
auf und auch gewalt waren keine
seltenheit
[Musik]
der finanz jedes damm projektes stammte
aus der familie vigano einer
wohlhabenden industriellen-familie aus
mailand vigano kritisierte die
ortsansässigen arbeiter in einer tour er
wollte lieber arbeiter aus mailand fast
so sehr schlechter stimmung führte
wenn nicht alle beteiligten gut
zusammenarbeiten gibt es mit dem bauwerk
am ende probleme
die bauarbeiten beginnen 1917 der erste
weltkrieg ist noch in vollem gange nach
einigen jahren müssen die planungen
aufgrund steigender kosten geändert
werden und die liga nur familie
beschließt am baumaterial zu sparen
[Musik]
beim bau der talsperre setzten sie
minderwertigen beton an und verstärkten
den mit granaten abwehr netzen
völlig untauglich für eine solche anlage
beschwerte sich ein arbeiter über die
materialien wurde er sofort gefeuert
das fundament ist bei jedem bau
entscheidend wenn man darin
metallschrott verbaut weiß man nicht
genau wieder zusammengesetzt ist
vielleicht ist da verrostet und wenn man
dann den beton dazu gehst ergibt sich
keine gute bindung zwischen metall und
beton was sehr wichtig für die
stabilität ist
war die katastrophe also zu erwarten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
als der damm im oktober 1923 endlich
fertig ist und der stausee erstmals
komplett gefüllt wird haben sich schon
probleme abgezeichnet
[Musik]
in diesem herbst hatte es besonders viel
geregnet das führte zu kleineren lecks
in der staumauer sie hätten eine warnung
sein sollen aber es hieß kein problem
die fortdauernden regenfälle lassen den
wasserpegel weiter und weiter steigen
und bringen die talsperre langsam aber
sicher an ihre grenze
am ersten dezember ist diese grenze
schließlich überschritten
der talsperren wärter ging seiner
üblichen prüfroutinen an der staumauer
nach als er plötzlich ein beben spürte
45 minuten später brach der damm
berichten zufolge gab es eine heftige
druckanstieg
die wassermassen in das darunter
liegende tal
etwa 4,5 millionen kubikmeter wasser
schießen mit einer geschwindigkeit von
rund 70 kilometern pro stunde durch das
loch in der staumauer
die katastrophe ist unausweichlich
das wasser war wie eine riesige
flutwelle ein tsunami voller geröll der
durchs tal fegte und alles mit sich riss
[Musik]
die flutwelle brauchte 45 minuten für
ihren weg durchs tal
[Musik]
sie zerstörte drei dörfer fünf
kraftwerke und unzählige einzelgebäude
und fabriken im tal
als das wasser schließlich abebbt haben
mehr als 350 menschen ihr leben gelassen
die vigano familie und die ingenieure
des damms werden für die katastrophe
verantwortlich gemacht aber die beteuern
ihre unschuld die anschließende
gerichtsverhandlung ist stark politisch
geprägt es werden widersprüchliche
beweismittel vorgelegt
letztlich bekommen die angeklagten wenn
überhaupt nur geringe strafen
danach legt sich fast 100 jahre lang
stille über die ereignisse bis benedetto
der bürgermeister eines der damals
zerstörten orte auf neue hinweise stößt
kurz nach dem zusammenbruch der
staumauer behauptete ein häftling im
gefängnis von cremona er habe eine
gruppe von anarchisten angeführt die
bomben platziert hätten um aufstrebenden
unternehmen zu schaden
[Musik]
auch ein kürzlich aufgetauchtes dokument
aus der gerichtsverhandlung legt nahe
dass der dammbruch auf einen anschlag
zurückzuführen sein könnte
da heißt es der richter habe den
weltweit renommiertesten experten
beauftragt ein gutachten zu erstellen
das kam zu dem schluss dass dort eine
bombe explodiert war
laut gutachten kann der wasserdruck
allein nicht zum zusammenbruch geführt
haben
darüber hinaus sollen kurz vor dem
unglück 75 kilogramm dynamit von der
baustelle verschwunden sein ein anschlag
könnte demnach tatsächlich eine
plausible erklärung sein
da die materialien und das fundament so
minderwertig waren ist es möglich dass
der sprengstoff größeren schaden
anrichtete als es eigentlich
beabsichtigt war
vielleicht war es ein verärgerter
arbeiter der sich an den videos rächen
wollte
oder es war einer der anarchisten die
damals kraftwerke in norditalien
angriffen
möglicherweise war es gar nicht das ziel
die talsperre vollständig zu zerstören
vielleicht sollte nur ein leck entstehen
um den betreibern wirtschaftlich zu
schaden
wir können es nicht mit sicherheit sagen
klar ist aber dass eine solche explosion
niemals derart katastrophale
auswirkungen hätte haben dürfen
bürgermeister unruhen ist überzeugt dass
die wahrheit vertuscht wurde weil es
schlecht ausgesehen hätte dass der
staudamm trotz der serie anarchistische
aktionen in der gegend nicht bewacht
wurde
95 jahre danach die wahrheit zu sagen
ist schmerzhaft menschen sind gestorben
ein ganzes gebiet wurde einfach
weggeschwemmt familien wurden
ausgelöscht und die geschichte eines
dorfes für immer begraben
[Musik]
über die jahrzehnte kamen öfter
überlegungen auf die kleine talsperre
wieder aufzubauen aber die finanzierung
kam nie zustande und so bleibt sie
weiterhin ein mahnmal der katastrophe
[Musik]
heute dient die talsperre als andenken
an den ehrgeiz ihrer erbauer und vor
allem an die vielen hundert menschen die
gestorben sind als die staumauer brach
[Musik]
nahe dem stadtzentrum von detroit im
us-bundesstaat michigan steht eine
ansammlung von gebäuden wie seit
jahrzehnten vor sich hin verfallen
[Musik]
die straßen sind verlassen die ganze
anlage erstreckt sich über mehr als
einen kilometer
[Musik]
das verblüffendste ist die größe der
anlage
sie scheint gar nicht mehr aufzuhören
[Musik]
sie wirkt wie eine industrielle
metropolis
ein relikt aus einer längst vergessenen
welt
[Musik]
alles ist völlig verwahrlost block neben
block neben block eingestürzte dächer
wasser auf dem boden fenster ohne
scheiben die natur bricht sich bahn
es wirkt wie die kulisse eines
horrorfilms
im inneren riesige leere räume komplett
verwüstet
diese höhlenartigen leeren räume wie ein
filmset für blade runner oder the
walking dead
ein unglaublicher ort man sieht wie er
über die jahre verfallen ist
aber wozu dienten diese gebäude und wie
kam es zu ihrem völligen verfall
[Musik]
die antwort liegt in der geschichte
eines produkts dass das erscheinungsbild
der usa entscheidend prägte das
automobil
[Musik]
bis ins frühe 20 jahrhundert reisen die
menschen per eisenbahn kutsche oder
dampfer
amerikanischen unternehmen bietet sich
ein riesiger markt für ein alternatives
neuartiges verkehrsmittel das auto
zunächst beschränkt sich die produktion
auf einen kleinen lokalen rahmen aber
bald wird klar nur mit massenproduktion
kann das potenzial dieser aufregenden
neuen erfindung voll ausgeschöpft werden
[Musik]
der anfang des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
steckte die amerikanische
automobilindustrie noch in den
kinderschuhen nur einer von zehntausend
amerikanern besaß ein auto und das waren
dann meistens noch dampf betriebene weil
das land so groß ist und die ortschaften
so weit auseinanderlägen brauchten die
amerikaner das auto dringender als alle
anderen
die schwierigkeit liegt darin genügend
autos herzustellen
frühere fabriken waren engen trist und
dreckig heute sieht es nicht mehr so aus
aber diese anlage war der beginn von
etwas ganz neuem
diese fabrik revolutionierte die art und
weise wie autos gebaut wurden die
arbeitsbedingungen waren besser und
dadurch auch die arbeitsmoral und
produktivität
[Musik]
die usa waren führend in bezug auf die
anzahl hergestellte autos vor allem auf
grund der besseren fabriken
deswegen konnten sie in kurzer zeit
viele autos produktionen time
einer der führenden automobilhersteller
war packard
[Musik]
das war das parkett automobilwerk 1903
beginnen die bauarbeiten und schon bald
übertrifft die anlage alle erwartungen
das packard werk war die modernste
autofabrik der welt
es erstreckte sich auf 14 hektar land
und hatte eine fläche von mehr als
300.000 quadratmeter
es setzte landesweit maßstäbe und die
produktionsraten gingen durch die decke
das geheimnis seines erfolgs ist der
eingesetzte stahlbeton
[Musik]
dieses material hat den fabrikbau
grundlegend verändert wie tourführer
jacob jones erläutert
[Musik]
auf diesem stockwerk war die montage
straße von packard sie zog sich über die
gesamte länge und erstreckte sich noch
ein stockwerk nach oben und 2 nach unten
die kombination aus stahl und beton
machte die struktur so belastbar fast
unzerstörbar hier entstanden einige der
besten luxuswagen der moderne gefahren
von alkohol und franklin roosevelt sie
entstanden in diesem stahlbetonbau
aber es gibt ein problem der preis ein
voll ausgestatteter pekhart kostet über
3000 dollar ein vor ort nur 850
wie kann packard da mithalten auch hier
kommt es auf die fabrik an nur hohe
qualität kann den hohen preis
rechtfertigen
und so entsteht praktisch jedes bauteil
eines jeden packard auf diesem gelände
[Musik]
dies gab unglaubliche 80
spezialabteilungen bei packard war alles
so dicht zusammen dass es leicht war
bauteile arbeiter und autos von a nach b
zu bewegen
zu spitzenzeiten arbeiteten dort bis zu
40.000 menschen
das unternehmen stellte mit die
hochwertigsten luxuswagen der usa her
sie bauten den sogenannten grave den
ersten frei verkäuflichen rennwagen der
vereinigten staaten der zum symbol für
packards erfolg wurde
in den anfangsjahren erzielt packard
einen erfolg nach dem anderen
aber der markt verändert sich als es
1929 zum börsenkrach an der wall street
kommt die weltwirtschaftskrise bricht
aus das geld wird knapp
[Musik]
wird das packard gelingen sich
umzustellen und mit konkurrenten wie
ford mitzuhalten
in den 1930 er jahren ändert seine
strategie und baut günstigere autos aber
dann treten die usa in den zweiten
weltkrieg ein
wie auch andere hersteller hörten sie
1942 damit auf autos zu bauen und
produzierten stattdessen rolls royce
triebwerke und schiffsmotoren für die
usa und ihre verbündeten
die unternehmen stellten für einige
jahre die kfz produktion ein das packard
werk und ähnliche fabriken trugen dazu
bei dass die alliierten den krieg
gewinnen konnten
in den nachkriegsjahren herrscht ein
enormer wettbewerb die großen brian ford
general motors und chrysler
dominieren nach wie vor den massenmarkt
aber die bauweise von luxuswagen
verändert sich und packard kann nicht
mithalten
[Musik]
beliebtheit nahm ab weil sie anderen
luxuswagenhersteller nichts entgegen zu
setzen hatten
ihre autos galten als weniger attraktiv
als sie hätten sein können sie wurden
als schwangere elefanten bezeichnet oder
als badewannen die autos waren einfach
nicht mehr beliebt
die verkaufszahlen gehen zurück und
packard ruf leidet
mitte der 1950 er jahre versucht das
unternehmen verzweifelt neue wege zu
gehen und schließt das werk
die anlage die dem unternehmen so große
erfolge beschert hat wird sich selbst
überlassen
wenige jahre später verschwindet die
marke packard vom automarkt
letztlich haben sich design und preis
von herstellern wie ford gegen packard
teurere modelle durchgesetzt
heute lassen ihre überreste kaum noch
erahnen wie sehr diese fabrik die
automobilherstellung verändert hat
nach hackers auszug nutzen andere firmen
zeitweise teile der gebäude aber wegen
unklarer besitzverhältnisse ist die
fabrik inzwischen größtenteils verfallen
[Musik]
heute ist das werk nur noch ein schatten
dieser damaligen welt es zeigt sehr
anschaulich wie schnell auch die großen
untergehen können
in estland steht nur rund 50 kilometer
von der hauptstadt tallinn entfernt eine
seltsame konstruktion an der küste
lange beton plattformen erstrecken sich
auf dem wasser
sie liegen in einer abgeschiedenen ecke
kaum jemand wusste damals genau was dort
vor sich hin es war alles streng geheim
wir waren klein und spielten am strand
als plötzlich 200 meter entfernt
und wir
was ist das
es gibt kaum noch hinweise darauf was es
mit dieser seltsamen anlage an mir einst
auf sich hatte
[Musik]
sie wirkt wie ein gerippe dass die
heftigen winde der see freigelegt haben
das war immer etwas ziemlich großes
etwas bedeutsames
das ist nicht einfach irgendein
industrie und handelshafen sport
ich weiß nicht genau wo zu der bau
diente aber erreicht drei stockwerke
tief ins wasser
wozu diente dieser anlage und warum
wurde sie verlassen
die antwort hängt mit dem kalten krieg
zusammen er beginnt 1947 mit der truman
doktrin in der präsident harry truman es
zum außenpolitischen grundsatz der usa
erklärt sich der sowjetischen expansion
entgegenzustellen
es folgen jahre des misstrauens zwischen
ost und west geprägt von der ständigen
gefahr eines atomkriegs
die lage im kalten krieg spitzt sich
1962 dramatisch zu als dieser jetzt
raketen auf kuba stationieren nur etwa
130 kilometer von den usa entfernt
[Musik]
im verlauf der krise schicken die
sowjets teils mit atomwaffen bestücktes
u boote auf strategische positionen im
atlantik
[Musik]
eine der heißesten schlachten des kalten
kriegs spielte sich unter wasser ab mit
geboten
die boote sind praktisch früher
tarnkappen waffen sie können sich
heimlich feindlichen küsten oder
marinestützpunkte nähern und dann
angreifen
die welt steht kurz vor einem atomkrieg
aber die ereignisse sind nicht auf den
atlantik und auf kuba beschränkt auch
gut 8000 kilometer entfernt in der
ostsee wappnet man sich
in der ostsee passierte damals eine
ganze menge
die russen nutzten die ostsee um mit
ihren besatzungen zu trainieren und
bessere u-boote und techniken zu
entwickeln
in estland wurde deswegen diese anlage
gebaut das ziel die weiterentwicklung
der u-boote der sowjetischen marine das
war der u boot hafen von
[Musik]
die einrichtung wird ende der 1950 er
jahre fertiggestellt damals ist sie
hochmodern und streng geheim
beim kalten krieg unter wasser geht es
nicht nur um feuerkraft sondern auch um
heimlichkeit und strategie
boote die an der oberfläche fahren
müssen vor allem schnell und effizient
sein u boote hingegen in erster linie
leise
die ostsee war für die geheimdienste ein
richtiger tummelplatz ständig von u
boote an der küste entlang um
militärische anlagen auszustellen und
kommunikation abzuhören
sie waren mit marschflugkörper für ziele
an land ausgerüstet und mit torpedos um
kriegsschiffe angreifen zu können aber
es ging vor allem um spionage
heute ist die anlage nur noch eine ruine
aber der abgeordnete art urteil weg kann
sich gut erinnern wie sie einst aussah
hier war alles voller kabel
über den beiden kreis erstreckten sich
brücken
und spezialkräne bewegten sich hin und
her um die boote mit den kabeln zu
bedecken u
boote mit kabeln zu überspannen klingt
ungewöhnlich das ist kein bestandteil
üblicher wartungs oder reparaturarbeiten
was also ging hier vor sich
welche rolle spielte der stützpunkt bei
der spionage in der ostsee
[Musik]
der springende punkt bei einem u boot
ist dass man es möglichst nicht finden
soll
allerdings erzeugen stehende objekte bei
der fahrt im wasser eine magnetische
signatur die mann aufspüren kann
in harra soll dieses problem gelöst
werden
es war ein end magnetisierung stützpunkt
an dem die magnetische signatur
sowjetische u-boote reduziert wurde
damit sie sich unbemerkt nato
marinestützpunkte nähern konnten
das eigentliche and magnetisierung ist
ein sehr schneller einfacher vorgang
schwierig ist das u boot in die anlage
zu kriegen und das dann anzuheben
wir kamen die u-boote rein
und dann wurde zunächst ihr magnetfeld
gemessen
man legte die kabel um sie herum ließ
spannung hindurch laufen und verringerte
so die magnetische signatur des gebots
das war es auch schon
danach sind die u-boote sehr viel
schwieriger aufzuspüren aber es geht
nicht nur darum für den feind möglichst
unsichtbar zu sein in diesen gewässern
lauern noch andere gefahren
[Musik]
der stützpunkt war auch wegen der magnet
mine in der nähe wichtig
1941 wurde hier eine der größten
seeschlachten der geschichte
ausgeformten die minen schlacht von jun
da
schätzungen zufolge wurden im zweiten
weltkrieg etwa 70.000 minen und andere
sprengkörper hier in die ostsee geworfen
es ist wahrscheinlich dass eine große
anzahl von minen mit magnet sender noch
immer hier liegt
[Musik]
eine magnet mine kann da ungestört
liegen bleiben bis irgendwann ein schiff
oder u boot vorbei kommt der
auslösemechanismus reagiert auf dessen
magnetische signatur und die mine
explodiert
die ent magnetisierung hält nur eine
gewisse zeit vor und dann baut sich das
magnetfeld wieder auf und der vorgang
muss wiederholt werden
wurden die sowjetischen u boote alle
here and magnetisiert oder gab es noch
weitere anlagen
die ent magnetisierung wurde nicht nur
am gemacht sondern in der ganzen buch
[Musik]
waren 18 kilometer kabel verlegt
die u boote fuhren eine woche oder
länger nur hin und her
bevor dann im hafen gemessen wurde ob
sie genügend magnetisiert waren oder
nicht
im verlauf des kalten kriegs spielte
hara so eine wichtige rolle in der
geheimen spionage schlacht in der ostsee
[Musik]
aber warum ist die anlage heute rund 30
jahre nach dem zerfall der sowjetunion
noch immer so geheimnisumwittert
[Musik]
die russen waren ziemlich paranoid was
ihre u boote anging unbefugte dürften
nicht mal in die nähe dieser anlage
kommen
niemand durfte wissen was da vor sich
gehen weil es so wichtig war die u boote
zu amp magnetisierten und dadurch
schwieriger auffindbar zu machen musste
der stützpunkt unbedingt streng geheim
bleiben
und die geheimhaltung endet nicht mit
dem kalten krieg bevor die russen
abzogen und estland unabhängig wurde
entkernten sie stützpunkte wie diesen
vollständig um ihre militärischen
geheimnisse zu wahren
das wenige das heute noch in harra zu
sehen ist vermittelt nur eine ahnung von
der vergangenheit dieser anlage die
ganze geschichte dieses u boot
stützpunkt wird wohl weiterhin ein
geheimnis bleiben
[Musik]
im nordosten polens steht verborgen in
den wäldern ein riesiger betonbau
[Musik]
einsam zwischen bäumen und wiesen findet
sich diese verlassene anlage
[Musik]
ein spaziergänger wäre sicher überrascht
sie wirkt fehl am platz mitten im wald
steht diese fremdartige anlage
[Musik]
grüne landschaft
wunderschöne stille wasser
warum dieser riesige betonklotz
mittendrin
was auch immer hier einst eingeschlossen
war kam so schnell nicht raus
aus der vogelperspektive ist das ganze
noch rätselhafte
in der mitte ist ein riesiges becken
ist es eine art kühlbecken da dass ein
kraftwerk
von außen führt ein wasserlauf hinein
vielleicht ist das ein hinweis
wozu wurde dieser massive betonbau hier
draußen in der polnischen landschaft
errichtet
und warum steht er heute verlassen in
den wäldern
der erste hinweis auf seinen ursprung
ist hoch oben im beton zu sehen
der beton ist über die jahre
ausgeglichen aber ganz oben sieht man
den umriss eines adlers
das bedeutet dass der bau mit dem
dritten reich zu tun hat es ist ein
reichsadler
seit 1933 sind die nazis in deutschland
an der macht hitler träumt von einem
deutschen weltreich
in der nacht vom 30 juni auf den ersten
juli 1934 verhaften und ermorden die
nazis praktisch die gesamte
führungsriege der as a ihrer
paramilitärischen kampftruppe in der so
genannten nacht der langen messer in der
errichtung seiner diktatur kennt hitler
keine gnade er lässt auf as a führer
ernst röhm einen langjährigen
verbündeten und unterstützer ermorden
im august verstärkt reichspräsident
hindenburg hitler lebt die ämter von
kanzler und präsident zusammen und lässt
sich fortan als führer und reichskanzler
bezeichnen deutschland wird eine
diktatur
als nächstes drückt die einstige
kornkammer deutschlands in den fokus
ostpreußen das nach dem ersten weltkrieg
vom reich abgeschnitten ist und
angesichts steigender spannungen in
europa besonders angreifbar scheint
hitler beschließt dass sich sein
weltreich selbst versorgen soll und
damit wird es sehr wichtig reichlich
getreide in ostpreußen anzubauen
aber ostpreußen liegt auch direkt neben
russland
hier hatten sich die gegnerischen
kriegsparteien nur zwei jahrzehnte zuvor
erbittert bekämpft
gab es heftige kämpfe
die region war ein brennpunkt
wenn sich deutschland während eines
krieges selbst mit nahrung versorgen
will muss es dieses gebiet verteidigen
können
aber in der provinz ostpreußen leben
längst nicht genug menschen um sie
verteidigen zu können
die nazis wünschten sich zwar ein dicht
bevölkertes ostpreußen aber die leute
wollten dort nicht leben viele zogen
fort
es war eine strukturschwache agrar
gegend
und wie bevölkert man ein gebiet man
investiert in infrastruktur dann werden
die leute schon kommen
[Musik]
deswegen wurde der kanal ausgehoben der
die masurische seenplatte mit der ostsee
verbinden sollte es war ein transportweg
für frachtgüter
ostpreußen brauchte eine
transportinfrastruktur um agrar gerät
und futter anliefern und
landwirtschaftliche produkte ausführen
zu können
diese riesige betonbauer sollte eine
schleuse im neu angelegten masurischen
kanal bilden das sind die überreste der
ober schleuse fürsten
der kanal sollte sich rund 50 kilometer
weit vom maurer bis in die alle
erstrecken
aber zwischen diesen zwei punkten gibt
es einen enormen unterschied
deswegen wurden schleusen wie diese
gebraucht
es gab insgesamt zehn schleusen entlang
des kanals durch die bis zu
siebeneinhalb meter breite schiffe
passten diese wurden darin angehoben
oder abgesenkt
das bemerkenswerte an diesem
schleusensystem ist dass es einen
höhenunterschied von 90 metern
überwindet das ist als würde ein boot
einen hügel hoch fahren und auf der
anderen seite wieder runter
schleusen ermöglichen es uns
geografische hindernisse zu überwinden
die wasser sonst nicht überwinden könnte
von allen schleusen des kanals ist diese
mit einer fallhöhe von 17 metern die
größte
[Musik]
funktioniert so es gibt zwei
verschiedene wasserspiegel das boot
fährt in die schleuse die tore schließen
sich dann läuft wasser in die schleuse
und hebt das boot so auf die höhe des
nächsten abschnitts
anschließend öffnen sich die tore auf
der anderen seite und das boot fährt
weiter
heute ist nur an einer seite der
schleuse wasser
gelang es den nazis damals den kanal
fertig zu stellen sie waren nicht die
ersten die es versucht haben
es sollte schon im neunzehnten
jahrhundert ein kanal gebaut werden der
ostpreußen mit der ostsee verbindet
aber das war wirtschaftlich nicht
tragfähig
und es gab nie genug öffentliche mittel
die nazis griffen die pläne wieder auf
am geld sollte es diesmal nicht
scheitern
[Musik]
das war ein sehr arbeitsintensives
projekt das sicher viele landarbeiter in
lohn und brot brachte die am
existenzminimum lebten
aber obwohl eine armee von arbeitern an
dem bauprojekt beschäftigt ist hat es
nach dem kriegsbeginn durch hitler 1939
keine priorität
hitlers ziel verschiebt sich von einem
autarken deutschland zur errichtung
eines weltreichs so dass der kanal in
ostpreußen keinerlei bedeutung mehr hat
der bau wird schließlich abgebrochen
[Musik]
in den 1944 hat sich das blatt längst
gewendet die rote armee drängt die
wehrmacht zurück
um den vorrückenden feind aufzuhalten
sprengen die nazis die brücken über den
unfertigen kanal
der syrische kanal sollte die
verkehrsinfrastruktur verbessern aber
das hat er nie stattdessen wurde er
kurzzeitig ein hindernis für die rote
armee aber nicht lange
[Musik]
heute verbirgt sich diese verlassene
anlage in den wäldern polens noch immer
erinnerte umriss des rechts adlers an
die großen pläne die die nazis hier
einst umsetzen wollten
[Musik]
hitlers anspruch der welt seinen willen
aus stahl und beton aufzuzwingen
scheiterte
dieser versuch die grüne landschaft
polens zu unterwerfen ist zur ruine
verfallen
hitlers tausendjähriges reich bestanden
nicht einmal lange genug um einen kanal
fertig zu stellen
[Musik]
ingenieurs und bauprojekte dem verfall
preisgegeben sie erzählen vom
fortschritt und erfindergeist aber auch
von krieg und terror von alldem wozu
menschen fähig sind
[Musik]